[Music]
right now
only 15 percent of life on earth lives
in oceans today we're gonna crank that
up a notch
you as well as all life on earth
are moving underwater would we have to
evolve
to pull this off species would thrive
and which species would draw the short
straw
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if all life on earth lived in the oceans
pack your bags because today we're
moving every living species on earth
underwater but
before we do let's see what we're
working with
it's estimated that eighty percent of
earth's
species live on land fifteen percent in
the ocean
and the remaining five percent in fresh
water
this is going to be a big move and in
order to pull this off
we're going to have to adapt and fast
for the sake of this video humans and
animals
are all going to make the evolutionary
jump and
adapt to breathing underwater oh your
nuke gills really
bring out your eyes
gills like the ones currently growing
from your neck
are a respiration system that use a
network of blood vessels
they draw in oxygen from flowing water
and
diffuse it through gill membranes
this would allow you to take in the
splendors of your new
underwater home and you know
not drown so now that your
mutated family and pets have made the
descent
what's life going to be like down here
anyway
well you may have to get over your fear
of the dark
both humans and animals would need to
develop
ways to battle darkness i'm talking
about developing
a better sense of touch and the ability
to sense vibrations
other ocean newbies may evolve to create
their
own light like the lanternfish in order
to attract
mates or prey imagine your cat
chasing its own light
it's also going to feel a lot colder
the cold environment is going to push
you into adapting your membranes to keep
them liquid
if you don't your fat will solidify
but we know you can handle this so
you'll have unsaturated fats in your
membranes so
that they can remain liquid and hey does
anyone else have a headache this is an
educated guess but i'm thinking the
eight
tons of added pressure per square inch
may be the culprit on the plus side
you're also going to have
a lot more room the pacific ocean
alone covers 165.2
million square kilometers that's larger
than
all the land on earth which measures in
at 148.94 million square kilometers
talk about an upgrade in real estate so
provided that you and your animal
friends get the evolutionary
upgrades you should be okay
but plants and bugs got the shaft on
this one
plants would need to rely solely on
wind for pollination this would make it
extremely difficult for
plant life to be successful underwater
bugs like ants and worms would bite the
dust and
that's a problem for our soil
this is because worms help nourish the
soil and ants help
to aerate it this is actually super
important
earthworms make nutrients more available
to plants
since they feed on plant debris
when they die the nutrients are
available for the plants to absorb
without this process the whole ecosystem
will
fall out of whack and that brings us to
a bigger point
everything on earth is connected in some
way
with everyone playing an important role
in the ecosystem of the planet
if we change the very fabric of how our
world is structured
it would change almost everything about
it from the plant life
to the gas contents of the atmosphere if
we packed up shop
and moved all life to the oceans we
would have much more space
the downside is life is going to be a
lot less diverse
thanks to the constraints of water and
lack of sunlight
so before we make any major moving plans
what if we give it a test run and build
a home away from home
what if we lived in cities underwater
well that's a story or another
what if